dr cleveland selected six drawings  depicting the logos of the scp  foundation the global occult coalition  the chaos insurgency the serpent's hand  marshall carter and dark limited and dr  wondertainment and prepared them for  testing with scp-914  all the drawings were placed into the  clockworks on the setting fine and this  was the output produced a comic scene  depicting the avengers the x-men and the  guardians of the galaxy fighting in new  york city a flag resembling the nazi war  flag with the hydra symbol in place of  the swastika is seen from a distance  several politicians including mayor bill  de blasio are seen evacuating manhattan  as the dark phoenix is about to destroy  it deadpool is also visible